- You and your brother
Shawn wrote "Scary Movie".
So did you like scary movies as kids?
'Cause I did not.
- I hated scary movies and I
think that's why we wrote them
because first of all, I couldn't
understand why the killer,
these girls are running and
bolting through the woods
and this killer is just (whistles)
walking and taking his
time and going for a stroll
and they're all (breathes heavily).
And he still catches him.
I don't get it.
So I wasn't scared.
The only one that really scared me
was "Nightmare on Elm Street"-
- Me too!
- Because I couldn't figure
out, like me and my brother
Shawn, we started drinking
coffee, we didn't go to sleep.
We was like nine and we
had my nephew at the time
when we watched it, we had it
on VCR and we got my little
nephew Craig, he was like four years old,
but he was thick and me and Shawn used him
as a teddy bear to watch the
movie 'cause we were scared.
- (laughs) He was thick.
Wait, that one wrecked me.
I would not even sit on a water bed
because of that Johnny Depp scene.
Those were messed up movies, anyway.
- I told you I started drinking
coffee at nine years old
thanks to that movie.
- So Halloween is big in New York,
but you guys didn't celebrate
his kids though, right?
- No, my dad was Jehovah's Witness,
so we didn't really celebrate any holiday.
So we didn't do that.
And plus we really couldn't
afford the costumes.
So me and my brother,
don't tell him my dad this,
well you can tell him now, he's 84,
he can't whoop our behind
now, but when me and Shawn
switched clothes and I
would go and they'd be like,
"Who are you?"
And I'd be like, "I'm Shawn."
And he be like, "I'm Marlon."
Because we switched clothes.
So it wasn't really a costume.
It wasn't, we was trick or treating,
we was just begging basically.
- We had no money, so I was queen
of just putting a sheet
on and cutting holes.
I'm a ghost, give me candy.
- Girl, you know what
kind of behind whoopin'
I would have got for cutting
holes in the sheet, you crazy.
(laughter)
My mother like, "That's my
good sheet, you know better!"
- Oh my god. (laughs)
I don't know, it was like the easiest,
cheapest thing I could do.
So my mom probably never
knew that, whatever,
they were my sheets, she never saw 'em.